welcome back okay so in the last video
we were looking at showing that
closed-loop control can do much better
than open with control when you have
model uncertainty and disturbances and
so to illustrate this we're looking at a
simple model for a cars cruise
controller where we're assuming just the
simplest dynamics of the car if I hit
the gas the car speeds up
instantaneously if I hit the brakes the
car slows down instantaneously and we're
comparing the open-loop in the closed
loop controllers so the open-loop
control is purely based on a model of
the car it doesn't take measurements and
it doesn't speed those measurements back
so the open-loop controller I'm saying
has a model of P equals two which means
if I hit the gas the car speeds up by a
factor of two but in reality because I
have some uncertainty in my model maybe
the true automobile dynamics are only
half as responsive maybe I'm used to the
car being responsive but my tires are
deflated my wheels are out of alignment
and maybe my fuel injectors need to be
cleaned and so I'm saying that my my
model for the car is inaccurate and in
reality it's only half as responsive so
the open-loop controller would say take
your reference desired reference speed R
and just divide it by two and that's how
you pass through the model to get y
equals to R to get your actual speed to
equal the reference but in the case
where my model was bad and maybe I also
have disturbances like these rolling
hills so this is kind of you know the
magnitude of these rolling hills is the
disturbance open-loop is going to be
really way far off it's not going to
track the reference speed well at all
it's going to be off by 50% because the
model is off by 50 percent and the
disturbance is going to pass right
through the open-loop controller because
it's not measuring anything okay so
we're going to show in that lab that
this is just really bad but if you close
the loop if you measure the speed and
you apply a proportional control to the
error between your reference speed and
your actual speed then you can get
really good
properties of your closed-loop system so
by choosing K large I can make my closed
loop lie very close to my desired
reference speed R and I can also
attenuate or reject my disturbances by
making one over one plus K really really
small so we're going to make this as
small as possible and this is close to
one as possible by choosing K large okay
now in a lot of applications there's a
limit to how large K can be maybe I'm
not driving a Ferrari maybe I just can't
just instantly bump up the RPM maybe
there's some dynamics involved maybe I'm
driving a Civic and there's actually
kind of a lag between when I hit the gas
and when the car gets going so we'll add
in dynamics later and we'll add in
limits on how big K can be later but for
now I get better reference tracking and
better disturbance rejection if I have a
big gain K in this proportional feedback
scheme okay so we're going to code this
up in MATLAB and we're going to plot the
open-loop response and the closed loop
response with some disturbances okay so
let me fire up MATLAB okay so this is a
premade script to run this it's called
cruise control dot M and the first thing
I'm going to do is I'm going to define a
time vector from zero to ten and
increments of 0.01 so I'm going to
integrate my car model for ten seconds
I'm going to say that my reference speed
my desired reference speed is 60 miles
per hour so I want my car to go 60 miles
per hour no more no less okay
and the way I get this is actually a
vector of 60 s as long as time so I take
sixty plus zero times time that makes a
big zero vector and I add 60 to it and
then I'm going to say that I have a
pretty large disturbance maybe I'm
driving through rolling hills in Montana
and every every couple of seconds I pick
up a plus or minus ten miles per hour so
I got these big hills in every couple of
seconds I'm going ten miles an hour
faster or ten miles an hour slower or 10
miles an hour faster ten miles an hour
slower now this is just a very crude
disturbance model that gives you the
idea
yeah of one of the servants could look
like okay remember my model for the
system my naive kind of factory issued
model is just a model equals two
that says P equals two that means that
if I hit the gas with one I get a Y of 2
okay but in reality my car is actually
only has a transfer function of 1 P is
equal to 1 here okay so it's not what
what my model says so you open loop is
just my reference so sometimes I call it
W R and W is usually a vector of
reference disturbance and noise and WR
is just the reference so my open-loop
control is my reference divided by my
model for peak so that's my reference /
- that's my open-loop control strategy
not a very good strategy and if I
compute my output Y open-loop is my true
P times you open loop plus disturbances
so why don't I just stop here and I'll
plot this this part here ok so I'm
running the top part and now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to plot T by Y
open loop and actually let's plot T by
my reference first so T by my reference
may be in black and then I'll hold on
and I'll plot T by my actual Y open loop
let's say in red
okay so you can see here my it's
actually a little hard to see but my
desired reference is right up here at
the top the black line at the top if I
wanted to I could say Y Lim 0 to 70 so
we can see this a little bit better okay
so my reference speed is 60 miles per
hour but my open-loop controller is
doing a really terrible job okay because
my model is off by a factor of two
instead of tracking at 60 miles per hour
it's tracking in an average of 30 miles
per hour and the disturbance is from my
rolling hills are passing right through
my open-loop controller and my speed is
all over the places
terrible control law I would not
recommend you get in the car
that uses open-loop open-loop cruise
control okay but now let's compute the
closed-loop the closed-loop control and
in this example I'm going to choose a
proportional gain of K equals 50 so
that's going to get us within about 2%
of the reference value and it's also
going to reduce the disturbance by also
about a factor of 50 okay and 1 over 51
so I'm choosing K equals 50 and I'm
plugging in this formula in MATLAB you
could actually simulate the system
dynamically in Simulink or reason the
feedback command but for now I know that
I've derived the closed-loop so I take
my closely model is the true transfer
function so P equals 1 times K so this
is P true here PK over 1 plus PK so PK
over 1 plus PK times my reference plus 1
over PK times my disturbance there's a
PK here but P is 1 for the true
automobile the true automobile transfer
function is just y equals u okay so now
we're going to plot our closed loop on
top so we're going to plot our reference
our open loop and our closed loop and
we're going to see how they all compare
okay and let's just run this all at once
and I
some nice scripts to make it look a
little cooler but you can see okay in
black is my reference speed that's just
this line right here I want to go sixty
miles an hour the disturbance here in
the black dash line this is the plus or
minus ten miles an hour just from the
rolling hills I just want to show you
the magnitude of the disturbance
open-loop is this red plot so remember
it's got a mean of 30 because the model
was off and the disturbance is passing
all the way through it so student a
terrible job but the closed-loop control
this blue curve is really really really
close to the reference you can see it's
wiggling a teeny bit and it's not
perfectly at the reference but it's
within about two percent of the
reference value and the disturbance is
this plus or minus ten miles per hour
has been reduced by a factor of 50 so
it's way way smaller
I could probably zoom in and just to
give you an idea so you can see that
it's actually not perfect right my my
close loop is not doing perfect but it's
doing pretty darn good we're within a
couple miles per hour of our desired
reference speed okay takeaways there is
a huge benefit for doing closed-loop
feedback control if I if my model is not
perfect open loop is going to be
operating on the wrong assumption and it
could be way off for reference tracking
right it could be like 50 percent off or
more if my model was bad if I have
disturbances and I do I'm not measuring
what the actual state of the system is
then open loop is going to let those
disturbances pass completely through but
with closed loop feedback control I can
make my system track references I can
make this close to one and I can
attenuate disturbances I can make this
close to zero and I can do a really
really good job so things will do in the
future are to reduce this steady-state
error to make the blue line perfectly
aligned with the the black line we can
also add some integral control this is
proportional we can add an integral term
integral of exelon so this is
proportional integral or P I control and
that's going to do a good job of closing
this gap we're also going to look at the
state the case where this transfer
function from gas to speed is
so simple right in a real car you hit
the gas you don't just instantly jump to
a higher speed there's some dynamic
acceleration and so if we build in a
more realistic model of the acceleration
and we build in a integral control law
we can do a much better job and also
model more realistic system okay so
that's all coming up but the major
takeaway is that closed loop control has
huge benefits if your system has
uncertainty and disturbances okay thank
you